brutalité qui avait conduit le
gouvernement à prendre des mesures
soudaine pour limiter la vie sociale
dans les jours qui ont immédiatement
précédé ce 15 mars c'est au vu de ces
conditions que le gouvernement avait
décidé de maintenir le premier tour des
élections municipales décisions parfois
contestées mais décision assumée
j'assume avoir considéré qu'un bureau de
vote était un lieu indispensable à la
vie du pays
j'assume d'avoir considéré comme le
conseil scientifique et au vu des
conditions d'organisation des bureaux de
vote qui avaient été mises en place
qu'il n'y avait ce jour là pas plus de
risque à aller voter
calais par exemple faire ses courses
j'assume surtout cette décision parce
que dans aucune démocratie on ne peut
décider en dehors de tout cadre légal
d'annuler un scrutin
la veille du jour où il doit se tenir le
premier tour des élections municipales
s'est donc tenue le 15 mars avec un taux
d'abstention significatif mais dans des
conditions rigoureuses de distanciation
physique et d'hygiène et je tiens à
remercier tous les assesseurs et toutes
les équipes municipales qui l'ont rendu
possible ce premier tour a permis
d'élire l'intégralité du conseil
municipal dans trente mille 143 communes
françaises dans ses 30000 143 communes
la vie municipale est en train de
reprendre son cours avec l'installation
ces jours ci des conseils municipaux
j'adresse d'ailleurs un salut
républicains à tous ces nouveaux élus
qui étrennent leur nouveau mandat
à l'issue de ce premier tour il reste
encore à organiser un second tour dans
près de 5000 communes pour lesquelles
environ 16 millions d'électeurs seront
appelés aux urnes
il reste également 1100
intercommunalités dont les conseils
communautaires ne sont pas complètement
renouvelée autant d'institutions qui
joue un rôle de premier plan dans la
réponse à la crise et qui seront le
moment venu aux avant postes de la
relance
autant d'institutions donc qui au besoin
de travailler d'investir et de se
projeter dans la durée pas pour leur
propre satisfaction ou pour leur propre
plaisir mais bien pour les françaises et
les français qui ont besoin des
institutions locales qui ont besoin que
celle ci que les mères à qui ils font
confiance puisse exercer dans de bonnes
conditions leur éminentes
responsabilités pour déterminer les
conditions dans lesquelles ce second
tour allait se dérouler nous avons
respecté point par point la loi du 23
mars dernier cette fois prévoyez un
calendrier et une méthode d'abord un
avis du conseil scientifique sur les
questions de santé entourant le scrutin
ensuite un rapport que le gouvernement
devait être adressée au parlement au
plus tard le 23 mai j'ai rendu public
mardi dernier l'avis du conseil
scientifique
chacun a pu en prendre connaissance pour
ma part j'en retiens quatre éléments
d'abord le conseil scientifique estime
possible et nécessaire de garantir la
sécurité sanitaire des opérations
électorales
le jour du scrutin dans les bureaux de
vote et formule en ce sens des
recommandations précises
ensuite le conseil scientifique insiste
plus spécifiquement sur les risques
sanitaires importants liés à la campagne
électorale il distingue bien les
opérations de vote de la campagne
électorale et il a dit que la nécessité
si des élections sont organisées dans
modifier profondément l'organisation
troisièmement le conseil scientifique
souligne que d'un point de vue
statistique la tenue d'un seul tour
plutôt que de 2 et de la nuit est de
nature à réduire les risques sanitaires
sachant que nous serions obligés
d'organiser deux tours de scrutin si
nous repoussions le vote au delà de
l'été enfin le conseil scientifique
appel à réévaluer la situation
épidémiologique dans les semaines qui
précéderont la date du scrutin avant de
prendre la décision que nous avons
traduite dans le rapport que le
gouvernement vient d'envoyer aux
présidents des deux assemblées
j'ai souhaité consulter l'ensemble des
forces politiques du pays
je veux remercier chacune d'entre elles
qui a participé à l' échange de mercredi
soir à matignon
cet échange s'est déroulé dans un esprit
de franchise et de responsabilité qui
fait honneur à notre démocratie
autour de la table la question difficile
de savoir si le second tour des
élections municipales devait avoir lieu
en juin ou non n'a pas fait consensus
les arguments s'opposent ils sont tous
puissants et éminemment respectable
certains ont souligné qu'une élection
avec une campagne rendue délicate compte
tenu des restrictions sanitaires
poserait des problèmes de sincérité du
scrutin et qu'il serait plus clair de
reprendre les choses à zéro
plus tard d'autres pour leur part ont
souligné la nécessité où nous sommes et
pour un long moment sans doute vivre
avec le virus et donc de faire vivre
notre démocratie
avec ce virus et malgré ce viol ce la
faire vivre et pas la mettre entre
parenthèses
ils ont souligné enfin le rôle clé que
les communes et les intercommunalités
devrait jouer dans la relance dans la
reprise de l'investissement public et
ont conclu à la nécessité de leur donner
rapidement des exécutifs pour ce faire
les mêmes ont souligné les incertitudes
qui s'attacherait à un nouveau report
qui peut dire que la situation de
l'épidémie sera significativement
meilleurs en septembre en janvier plutôt
qu'en juin
tout ce qu'il soit favorable ou non à la
tenue d'élections en juin ont rappelé la
nécessaire attention l'indispensable
attention à la sécurité sanitaire
il appartient donc désormais au
gouvernement de prendre et d'assumer
seul sa décision
la question est complexe elle suscitera
des désaccords mais la clé pour le
gouvernement réside dans la cohérence de
ces décisions la semaine prochaine
nous présenterons au président de la
république la deuxième phase du plan de
déconfinement que nous avons voulu dès
l'origine prudent progressif et
réversible pour qu'eux aussi sûrement
que possible la vie économique
la vie sociale la vie démocratique
la vie privée même puissent reprendre
leurs droits face au virus
après avoir pesé le pour et le contre
nous pensons que la vie démocratique
elle aussi doit reprendre tous ses
droits c'est pourquoi le 27 mai prochain
nous présenterons au président de la
république un décret qui appellera les
électeurs à se rendre aux urnes pour le
second tour des élections municipales le
28 juin prochain les électeurs de
nouvelle calédonie et de polynésie
française seront également convoqué à
cette même date pour le second tour des
élections municipales
ce ne sera pas un second tour comme
avant si j'ose dire avec les maires qui
organise le scrutin avec les candidats
et leurs équipes de campagne
nous avons la double responsabilité
d'assurer à la fois la sécurité de ceux
qui participent au processus électoral
et la sincérité du scrutin
comme nous l'avions déjà fait pour le
premier tour le ministre de l'intérieur
va engager dès la semaine prochaine la
concertation avec les maires de france
pour organiser en toute sûreté
les opérations électorales proprement
dit en suivant précisément les
recommandations du conseil scientifique
le ministre de l'intérieur va également
poursuivre la concertation avec les
organisations politiques pour adapter la
campagne à la situation sanitaire la
sincérité du scrutin donc le bon
déroulement de la campagne sont des
condition sinequanone au bon
fonctionnement d'une démocratie
si cette concertation fait apparaître
qu'il est nécessaire de faire évoluer
telle ou telle disposition réglementaire
nous pourrons le faire
je pense notamment à l'assouplissement
des règles relatives aux procurations
cohérence encore comme toutes les
décisions prises dans le cadre du
déconfinement celle de tenir le second
tour des élections le 28 juin prochain
est réversible
nous aurons donc comme le recommande
d'ailleurs le conseil scientifique et
comme toutes les forces politiques l'ont
souligné
une clause de revoyure elle interviendra
sans doute dans deux semaines en effet
dans l'hypothèse où ce second tour ne
pourrait pas avoir lieu
il faudrait garder le temps nécessaire à
l'examen par le parlement du cadre légal
qui permettrait d'organiser un nouveau
report des élections glisse
c'est la raison pour laquelle et j'ai
conscience d'entrer dans des
considérations très juridique
c'est la raison pour laquelle sera
également présentée pour quelque sorte à
titre conservatoire le 27 mai prochain
en conseil des ministres un projet de
loi qui permettrait le report des
municipales au plus tard jusqu'en
janvier 2021 dans l'hypothèse où le
conseil scientifique nous dirait et en
deux semaines que les conditions
sanitaires ne seraient plus réunies pour
le 28 juin voilà le choix que présente
aujourd'hui le gouvernement c'est le
choix de la cohérence
c'est un choix exigeant et dont nous
allons suivre jour après jour jusqu'au
28 juin la mise en oeuvre je sais
pouvoir compter sur les mers et sur leur
équipe pour nous aider à l'organiser
dans de très bonnes conditions et je
sais pouvoir compter sur l'engagement de
nos concitoyens de nos concitoyennes à
participer à ce moment démocratique
essentiel que constitue l'élection des
équipes municipales
je vais à présent laisser la parole au
ministre de l'intérieur pour qu'il
présente les enjeux de la concertation
avec les maires et avec les
organisations politiques pour que
ensemble nous réussissions ce rendez
vous démocratique
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
la décision du premier ministre marque
une étape forte dans la reprise du cours
normal de notre vie démocratique assurer
la protection de toutes celles et tous
ceux qui font vivre notre démocratie
voilà notre impératif et ce second tour
nous impose donc collectivement
incivisme une vigilance et une
discipline partie
hier la campagne électorale ne doit pas
devenir un facteur de circulation du
virus
il conviendra donc de faire campagne
différemment différemment dans le
respect systématique des gestes
barrières et de l'ensemble des
préconisations du conseil scientifique
différemment on prenons toutes les
précautions nécessaires lors des
contacts entre les candidats leurs
équipes et des électeurs je pense à la
distanciation physique bien sûr mais
aussi au port du masque quand cela est
nécessaire
différemment enfin parce que il sera
utile de privilégier les campagnes
numériques et les interventions et
débats dans les médias
nous pourrons aussi réfléchir par
exemple à des professions de foi plus
détaillée plus longue
évidemment nous le savons il s'agit de
changements importants dans nos
habitudes de citoyens nous allons
travailler comme le premier ministre
vient de le rappeler avec les
associations d'élus et des partis
politiques
dès la semaine prochaine mais je veux
souligner que contrairement aux cours
normal d'un second tour d'élections
municipales où les candidats ne dispose
que de cinq jours de campagne et où il
est bien rare qu'il y ait plus d'une
réunion publique qui souhaitent
organiser les candidats et leurs équipes
auront cette fois ci quasiment un mois
devant eux un mois qui leur permettra de
convaincre les électeurs de faire valoir
leurs programmes et leurs convictions
tout en adaptant en adaptant leur
méthode à travers la france les
candidates et candidats aspirent à la
confiance des français dans cette
mission si importante
si sensible d'être mère j'ai confiance
dans leur esprit de responsabilité dans
celui de leur équipe et nous comptons
sur eux
concernant les opérations de vote notre
devoir est d'assurer la pleine sécurité
sanitaire des électeurs comme de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui tiendront les
bureaux de vote président assesseurs
employés municipaux et scrutateur tout
d'abord pour permettre à chacun le libre
accès au vote
nous allons comme au premier tour tout
faire pour faciliter les modalités de
recueil des procurations
il s'agit d'une organisation adaptée par
exemple pour les résidents des ehpad
il s'agit de permettre aux personnes les
plus vulnérables de demander la venue
d'un officier de police
judiciaire à leur domicile pour établir
une procuration nous veillerons à
simplifier au maximum du cadre légal le
processus le jour du scrutin dans les
bureaux de vote
toutes les mesures nécessaires seront
prises pour assurer la sécurité
sanitaire de tous les gestes barrières
et de distanciation physique devront
être respectées le cas échéant en
réaménageant les bureaux de vote ou de
façon plus simple par un marquage au sol
chaque électeur devra porter un masque
de protection qui pourra être un masque
grand public
ils devront également pouvoir disposer
de gel hydro alcoolique ou d'un accès à
un point d'eau pour se laver les mains
enfin les membres du bureau de vote
devront porter un masque chirurgical
tout au long de l'opération de vote tout
comme les scrutateurs au moment du
dépouillement
j'ajoute que la fourniture des masques
de gel sera assuré par les communes avec
le soutien plein et entier de l'êta
par ailleurs nous aurons l'occasion de
le rappeler mais des électeurs seront
invités à utiliser leur style au
personnel lors de l'émargement et à
présenter et manipulé eux mêmes leurs
pièces d'identité ce sont aux bonnes
pratiques faciles à mettre en oeuvre et
qui permettront de minimiser au maximum
les contacts lors du premier tour et
dans un délai contraint les communes
avaient accompli un travail remarquable
qui avait permis le respect des
consignes sanitaires dans les bureaux de
vote et je veux comme le premier
ministre l'a fait précédemment les
saluer nous avons aujourd'hui un mois un
mois pour préparer
je sais pouvoir compter sur l'engagement
sur la responsabilité des mais avec
l'appui des prêts faits pour organiser
au mieux ce scrutin mesdames et
messieurs le 28 juin
et si la situation sanitaire le permet
toujours 16 5 millions de français
pourront élire leurs conseils municipaux
dans près de 5000 communes
voter c'est l'acte le plus fort de notre
démocratie
tout sera mis en oeuvre pour qu'il
puisse s'accomplir en toute sécurité
dans le respect des règles sanitaires
je vous remercie
peut-être répondre à quelques questions
que vous vous poseriez sur ces annonces
monsieur merci patrick relevé le monde
vous dit enfin visiblement les
concertations entre démerder avec les
maires et avec les chefs de partis
politiques
il n'y a pas eu de consensus sur juin où
après les voilà pour cette déclaration
conjointe du premier ministre et du
ministre de l'intérieur on va tout de
suite retrouvé devant l'hôtel de
matignon notre reporter david khalifa
bonjour david plusieurs annonces au
sujet de l'organisation du second tour
des municipales qui se déroulera donc